Bob Geldof and a host of stars doing what the musician and campaigner claims...
...many governments are failing to do effectively: tackle Ebola.
The charity single was released on Monday.
The response, says Geldof, has been "manic."
The organizers insist that a hundred percent of the proceeds...
...will go towards the relief effort.
Ebola has killed more than 5,000 people, mostly in West Africa.
The song was first recorded 30 years ago,...
...a unique moment in the history of pop in Britain:...
...creating the charity single.
Can you spot the lineup?
It includes global stars like Bono.
But critics point out only one African-born performer is in the lineup,...
...while interest is also focused on those who turned down their invitations...
...like Adele and David Bowie.
Who will turn up for the European versions?
It's rumored Carla Bruni will appear on the French recording.